Okay.
So Michael, for the last 15 minutes or
so we've been talking about decision
trees, sort of in the abstract without
saying too much about the kinds of
functions they can actually represent.
So, for the next few minutes or so I
want to talk a little bit about not just
decision trees in the abstract, but
exactly how expressive they can be.
Is that okay?
>> Yeah,
I think that would be really helpful.
>> I think so too.
So in fact, I want to look
at a set of functions, and
in particular I'm interested in
looking at Boolean functions.
>> Boolean.
>> So what's your favorite
simple Boolean function?
>> Implication.
>> What's your other favorite
simple boolean function?
>> Well I like Nor.
>> Right.
So what I
just heard you say is you like And,
so let's do that one.
>> Oh, that's great.
That is my favorite.
>> All right.
So, in fact, let's do very simple And.
So, how does And work, right?
So, you've got two attributes.
Let's say A and B.
And, this expression,
A and B, is true when?
>> When A and B are true.
When they are both
true at the same time.
>> Right, exactly.
So, how would you build a decision tree,
given that there are only two attribute,
A and B, to represent that function?
>> Okay so
I'd have a note that's A and B.
And if that's true.
>> Nope, you're not allowed to do that.
>> Oh.
>> Every node can be,
have at most one attribute.
>> All right well let's
let's put A in an attribute.
>> Okay, so here's a little node.
Let's call it A.
>> Okay.
>> Now what?
>> And well I mean, for
it to be a node it needs to have
the little two branchy things.
True and false.
>> Okay.
All right, so how about true on
the left and false on the right?
>> Sure, as long as you label them.
So, all right.
So then A, if A is true,
okay, I don't know.
But oh, but if A is false,
then we know that A and B must be false.
Doesn't matter what B is.
So we can just put a leaf under the F.
>> That's correct.
All right, I like that.
>> Okay.
What about when A is true?
>> What, is that an F?
>> That is an F, and
that is a minus sign for false.
>> Oh, a minus sign.
I get it, okay.
I thought you were just not
done drawing the F yet.
>> good.
All right.
So, oh yeah.
On the true side then,
I don't think we know.
So I think we need to split on B also.
>> Okay.
>> So put a little B under there.
>> All right, done.
>> All right, and
then true-false split on B.
All right and so
now we've got these two cases.
So if B is false, then again,
it doesn't matter what A was but
A turns out to be true.
But it's still the, the, it should
be a minus sign underneath that.
>> Okay.
>> So it's not A and B is not true.
But if A is true and
B is true then A and B is true.
So there should be
a plus sign on the left.
>> That's exactly right.
>> Woo.
>> So clearly decision trees proof by,
we just drew it here,
can represent the Boolean function And.
>> Sure.
>> [CROSSTALK].
>> You said something int,
you said something interesting, Michael.
You said it doesn't matter
what A is if B is false.
So what would happen if I switch,
A and B around.
>> That's the same.
So if B, okay, in the beginning,
we say, if B is false, it's false.
If B is true, we check A.
If A is false, then it's false.
But if A is true, then it's true.
So it actually still represents
exactly the same function, A and B.
Oh, because A and B is collaborative.
No, commutative.
Yes?
No?
Hello?
>> It's one of those things.
It's commutative.
As opposed to associative.
>> As opposed to what?
>> Associative.
>> Well I mean it, it's that too.
But I mean, it's the reason that you
can just switch those two things and
it didn't make a difference is because
they play the same role in the function.
>> That's true in, in terms of
representation of the decision trees.
You know, it doesn't really matter
which attribute you pick or
the order in which you do them.
You might get a better tree or a worse
tree or a longer tree or a shorter tree.
But for something simple like,
two valued And,
it really just doesn't matter.
>> Okay.
>> kind of neat, huh?
>> Yeah.